hello everyone it's seven o'clock and
the strikes go on we're facing the worst
week of world disruption for 30 years
the finger pointing and blame games
continue the strikes are now into their
eighth month and there's a warning this
morning that millions of people will
simply avoid using the trains in the
future we'll hear from the transport
secretary Mark Harper in a few minutes
time followed soon after by the leader
of the rail Workers Union Mick Lynch it
is Tuesday the 2nd of January
new year new strikes commuters facing
the worst week yet on the railways
I'm live at Houston Station on day one
of five of consecutive rail strikes as
two unions join forces to put much of
the network out of use
we're live in Kiev as the Kremlin admits
that scores of its soldiers were killed
in a Ukrainian rocket attack
a British couple confirmed among four
people who died in a mid-air Collision
on Australia's Gold Coast
the government is urged to act over
warnings the pressure on the NHS is
unbearable and intolerable
the return of face masks new guidance on
return to school says adults feeling
unwell should cover up
after three days of national mourning
the burial of the Brazilian football
legend Pele will take place today in Sao
Paulo
it's veganuary and if you're going vegan
and that's one of your New Year
resolutions we'll hear when experts tips
on making it a tasty challenge
foreign
[Music]
pays to the child prodigy Earth Wind and
Fire drummer Fred white who has died at
the age of 67.
[Music]
hello and good morning and a happy New
Year it's the first full day of business
following the festive break and
commuters are facing five consecutive
days of travel disruption now ministers
fear that millions of passengers will
give up on train travel altogether as a
result of the worst week of real
disruption in 30 years now it comes as
the rmt warns that strikes on the
railway will continue until the
government stops blocking a deal to
resolve the bitter dispute of a pay jobs
and conditions later in the show we'll
be speaking to the transport secretary
Mark Harper as well as to the boss of
the rmt mick Lynch now the rail dispute
is just one of a number of damaging
strikes that the country will face
through January
Royal workers will be on strike from
today until Friday and workers on the
Elizabeth line through London on the
12th
London bus drivers will walk out on
seven days throughout the month
Highway workers and driving examiners
will be on strike in the first week of
the new year
paramedics will walk out on the 11th and
23rd
and nurses will strike again on the 18th
and 19th of January
well joining me now from Houston Station
is our Aisha zahid Aisha good morning to
you so we can see the picket line there
has formed more strike action coming
morning Kamali well we're starting the
year just as the last one left off more
strike action on the railways more
widespread disruption and that's because
as you said rmt are taking uh doing two
lots of 48-hour walkouts the first lot
taking place from today into tomorrow
and then again on Friday and then on top
of that the one day during the working
week where they're not taking strike
action is Thursday but that's when as
left Union the drivers Union will be
walking out as well so all of this
combined together is going to mean
widespread disruption on the railways
limited services and reduce schedules
running and where people are lucky
enough to get onto the trains there are
going to be most likely later start
times and earlier finishes as well so
the message from train operators is
really to check before they head out to
see if their trains are running and to
account for longer wait times and to
only travel if it is absolutely
necessary now rmt General Secretary
Lynch has said that the government's
been sitting on their hands and time and
time again the unions have emphasized
they don't want to be taking strike
action but they have to because no one's
listening overpay and conditions in
response the government said well its
biggest concern is increasing wages
could worsen inflation but the
government say that they've been
reasonable and that and that they're
ready to facilitate an end to this real
disruption
all right for now thank you for that and
let me just remind you that it's 20 past
seven I'll be speaking to the transport
secretary Mark Harper and then just
after that the General Secretary of the
rmt mick Lynch will be joining us
now Russia has suffered one of its
deadliest attacks since the start of the
war in Ukraine its defense Ministry has
admitted that 63 soldiers were killed in
a missile strike that destroyed eight
temporary barracks in eastern Ukraine
now Ukraine claims that up to 400
Russian soldiers were actually killed in
the strika correspondent user El bagir
is in Kiev for us this morning good
morning to you nice to have you with us
so what do we know about this the
Russians saying it's 63 ukrainians
saying 400 uh where are you with this
and as of now the Ukrainian Armed Forces
says they're investigating the number of
casualties but they put out a statement
and said that Ukraine launched 13
attacks on areas of concentration of
Russian troops in the last 24 hours and
that Russian army had launched six
missiles 52 airstrikes and over 70
multiple launch rocket system attacks so
there is an acknowledgment from the
Ukrainian armed forces of how many
missiles they launched into areas of of
Russian army concentration but still
trying to investigate the number of
casualties 63
admitted by the Russian defense Ministry
still a significant figure it still
makes this one of the deadliest attacks
in the war so far people are saying that
it's likely to be on the lower end of
the scale but still quite significant
it's important to remember that the
donesk region does have journalists does
have people there that would make it
quite difficult to hide an event with
this much loss of life so this
acknowledgment again is quite surprising
but still would have to happen the lack
of transparency would be difficult at
this time but we have seen an
intensification of aerial attacks over
the last week on both sides
zelenski and his evening address said
that Russia would be launching a
protracted drone campaign to exhaust
Ukraine and over the last two days three
days we've seen 84 drones at least
according to the Ukrainian Armed Forces
fired into Ukraine many of them over
Kiev so as well as the fighting that's
happening on the front lines in the
South and the East it's also there are
attacks here in Kiev hundreds of miles
hundreds of kilometers away get used to
it for now thank you
and the Sky News Daily podcast there's a
new mini series to start the year if you
scan that QR code that you see on your
screen right now you can listen to Neil
Patterson in conversation with the
Ukrainian MP Kidder Reddick you can
listen And subscribe wherever you find
your podcasts
or still to come on the program this
morning at 20 past seven we'll be
speaking to the transport secretary Mark
Harper on all things strikes
and at half past we'll be hearing from
the head of the rail Union the rmt
that's Mick Lynch
at 7 45 I'll speak to the former Health
secretary and former chair of the NHS
Confederation Stephen Doral as the
government is urged to act it's over
warnings with the pressure on the NHS is
unbearable
and sticking with that the government
has been warned that that pressure on
the NHS is becoming quite intolerable
and is facing calls to do more to help
the service through its winter of Crisis
the British Medical Association says
that staff are desperately trying to
keep up with incredibly high levels of
demand and they've accused the
government of failing even to discuss
the issues
or more than a dozen NHS trusts and
ambulance services have declared a
critical incidence over the festive
period
the Royal College of emergency medicine
says that up to 500 people are dying
each week as a result of the delays and
problems with urgent and emergency care
a Department of Health and Social care
spokesperson said in response we
recognize the pressures the NHS is
facing following the impact of the
pandemic that's why we've backed the NHS
and social care with up to 14.1 billion
pounds in additional funding over the
next two years
the British Medical Association though
says that the government's political
choices were leading to patients dying
unnecessarily
Matthew Simpson waited 16 hours and 45
minutes for an ambulance to arrive when
his wife Teresa felt ill he blamed the
delay for her death as health Chiefs
admit the NHS is facing significant
pressure
100 I believe that if they got to my
wife in six out in within the six hours
say from three to nine o'clock my wife
would still be here now she would not be
she wouldn't I'm 100 that she would
still be here today because she would
have got the hell
if if you look and make international
comparisons you'll find that many many
Health Systems as they're coming out of
the pandemic are seeing higher levels of
mortality than you would traditionally
expect so the same is that is the case
in Germany and Italy and Spain I think
it probably is fair to say that
certainly talking to Frontline staff
talking to Frontline Chief Executives
this does feel like it's the most
significant degree of pressure that we
face
now police in Australia say that a
British couple on holiday were among the
four people who were killed in a mid-air
collision between two helicopters on the
Gold Coast yesterday
well let's bring in uh Nicole Johnson
who's joining us now live Nicole good to
have you with us so what more do we know
about this incident on the Gold Coast
well Sky News has received a statement
from the family of the British couple
Diane and Ron Hughes they were both
killed in that crash the family has said
that they're heartbroken that they're
still trying to contact family and
friends and that they would like privacy
at this devastating time let's take a
listen to queensland's police
commissioner for some more detail on
that freak accident
what we do know at this very early stage
of the investigation is that one
helicopter was taking off that's had
seven people on board another one coming
into land with six people on board now
they've collided the one helicopter that
was taking off appears its main rotors
have collided with the landing
helicopter
that first helicopter took off and
collided with the second helicopter as
we just heard the first helicopter lost
all of its blades and its engine it
crashed down around 200 meters it landed
the wrong side up and as we know four
people were killed including the pilot
and an Australian woman who was there on
holidays with her nine-year-old son
another three people were injured two of
them children the big question now
though is how did this happen and what
can the officials do to try and make
sure that an accident like this never
happens again it was quite remarkable
though that the helicopter pilot for the
second helicopter that was trying to
land he managed to get it to the ground
the right side up even though it was a
severely damaged and smashed all the
glass at the front of that helicopter
and everyone in that helicopter survived
with minor injuries there's now a
serious investigation the underway
looking into how this accident came
about this is a major tourist area and
there are helicopter flights like this
along the Gold Coast all summer hundreds
of them taking in the long sandy beaches
there so it's a major concern for the
tourist industry but the big worry is of
course what happened to the Pilot's line
of sight because they do depend on line
of sight to make sure that these mid-air
collisions don't happen but clearly in
this case something went seriously wrong
indeed all right Nicole for now thank
you
all right let's look at some of today's
other headlines now and face masks are
back as schools reopen at this week
adults who feel unwell and go out are
being advised to wear a mask the health
Security Agency is also urging children
to stay home if they feel unwell or have
a fever to cut down on levels of flu
covered and strep a
an American football player is in a
critical condition after getting a heart
attack or suffered Cardiac Arrest during
a game the Buffalo Bills player Damar
Hamlin collided with another player in
the first quarter the game was suspended
as an ambulance drove onto the field he
was given CPR before being taken to
hospital for care
and the actor Jeremy Renner remains in a
critical but stable condition in
hospital after an accident with a
snowplow it's reported that he suffered
blunt chest trauma and Orthopedic
injuries and was in intensive care after
undergoing surgery
an investigation has begun after three
people and the dog died following a fire
at a hotel in Scotland Emergency
Services were calls to the new County
hotel in Perth and what's the fire
service called a very complex incident
11 people were treated at the scene
the Irish Prime Minister has admitted
that mistakes were made on all sides in
the handling of brexit as it affected
Northern Ireland Leo varadka conceded
that the Northern Ireland protocol may
have been a little bit too strict and
says he would be flexible and reasonable
in trying to solve the issues
I'm sure we've all made mistakes in the
handling of uh brexit there was no
road map no manual um it wasn't
something that we expected would happen
and we've all done our best to deal with
it
um I again look forward to traveling to
Northern Ireland early in the new year
and meeting with all the parties and
reaching out to all parties and all
communities in an effort to find a
solution
now tens of thousands of mourners have
paid their respects the former Pope
Benedict the 16th on the first day of
him lying in state around 65 000 people
including the Italian Prime Minister
filed through Saint Peter's Basilica in
the Vatican
now the Brazilian football legend pele's
burial takes place this afternoon
following three days of national
mourning now the last 24 hours thousands
of people have paid their respects to
the 82 year old who died last week as
his coffin lay in States at the home of
his former Club Santos from there are
Jackie beltrell sent us this
The Return of the King to his beloved
Santos was welcomed with flags flares
and fans singing his name on Monday
morning
as he was transported back to the pitch
that made Pele a superstar his home
ground Villa balmero
placing him on the center circle one
last time was a little less smooth than
his fans had been used to seeing in life
it was a traditional open casket as his
family said their goodbyes with his son
egino saying a quiet prayer
the first fans to file past his coffin
had queued overnight desperate not to
miss their chance to reflect on an
incredible life
first in the queue was solo who traveled
from rural Sao Paulo to be part of
history
when I saw him lying there I wished it
wasn't him but that is the reality we
are faced with today there's no question
that man was Edison Arantes de nacimento
Pele the king he will forever live in
our hearts and memories for generations
to come
thousands have the same idea dressed in
the iconic colors of Brazil or the black
and white of Santos some making the
pilgrimage from all over the world
well I was born in Saint Lucia
originally and growing up when I played
soccer he was the first black person who
recognized as one of the greatest and
everybody on the island wanted to be
killing and when I moved to New York I
saw him played at the cosmos in New York
for Cosmos together with friends friends
Beckham she landed on a terrible day for
Brazil and thought I can't miss this
I've grown up with football I love
football and yeah I had to come here and
uh and share the uh pillow Center pride
of sharing this with her with everyone
that's here thank you because it's he
was the king of football and of course
players he'd been inspiring for
Generations
Edison Arantes de nacimiento wasn't born
here he didn't die here but for 19
Seasons he put this place on the map so
much so that the Brazilian government
made him an official national treasure
and he couldn't play anywhere else
at 10 o'clock he'll be taken along the
beach in A procession through the
streets of Santos past his mother's
house and then to his final resting
place just 200 meters away from the
stadium close enough to still hear the
crowd Roar Jackie Bell trout Sky News
Santos
well it's just days now until the
release of Prince Harry's Memoir in
clips from two television interviews
Harry said he wants his brother and
father back but that they have made
absolutely no uh sign of willingness
that they wanted to reconcile
on a family not an institution they feel
as though it's better to keep us somehow
as the villains they've shown absolutely
no willingness to reconcile every single
time I've tried to do it privately there
have been briefings and leakings and
planting of stories against me and my
wife and that correspondent will
literally be spoon-fed information and
write the story and then the bottom of
it they will say that they've reached
out to Buckingham Palace for comment but
the whole story is Buckingham Palace
commenting so when we're being told for
the last six years we can't put a
statement out to protect you but you do
it for other members of the family there
becomes a point when
silence his betrayal
well the new year is dominated by
concerns about the NHS and rail strikes
of course joining us now is the
transport secretary Mark carbamark uh
Harper Happy New Year to you good
morning Happy New Year to you we're
going to come on to the rail strikes of
course in a moment I want to start with
the A E I know if you've been watching
our show this morning we had a chaplain
called Matthew Simpson who talked about
his wife Teresa who died waiting 16
hours at any I mean what do you say to a
family that has had to wait all that
time to get treated in our Health
Service well look I didn't didn't see
the package but obviously my enormous
sympathies are with that family and
that's clearly not an acceptable length
of time for anybody to wait and I
recognize that the Health Service is
under pressure this winter that's why
the government's made extra resources
available not actually just for the
Health Service but also importantly for
social care to make sure that people who
are well enough to leave Hospital are
able to do so we made extra resources
available so that that help can get onto
the front line and that's what I know
ministers are working very hard to do so
I accept it's tough at the moment
because we're dealing with the you know
also the pandemic high level of flu and
the normal winter pressures on top of
that but that's why we've made those
extra resources available on helping
families like Matthew Simpsons and not
helping those families but you've seen
reports people had to wait 99 hours for
treatment yes and one of the real issues
is about making sure that people who are
well enough to leave Hospital are able
to leave that's why it's important that
the Health and Social Care Systems are
working together that's why we made half
a billion pounds 500 million pounds
available before Christmas and that
money is getting to local councils and
local health services so they can work
together to to get the system unblocked
and that's what will then feed through
into a faster response into emergency
departments and a faster response for
ambulance so when are people going to
see that because it's not just that
money I mean that money is very welcome
of course everyone will say that but
this is years and years of under
investment in the health services no
well I don't agree with that we put of
extra money into the Health Service
every single year and there's record
levels of investment into the Health
Service in real terms we've got uh
thousands more doctors and thousands
more nurses working in the Health
Service you know there are 130 000
vacancies in the Health Service there
are huge discrepancies in those figures
well no look there are significantly
more doctors and nurses working in the
Health Service we do think it's
important to look at Workforce uh in the
long term that's why the chance to set
that out in the Autumn statement and
that's why the Health Service is working
on that long-term Workforce for a plan
at the moment which will be published in
the coming months okay let's come on to
your brief and the transport strikes
there was reporting before Christmas
that ministers have got involved at the
last minute and have put a block on a
deal being signed between the union and
the rail delivery groups is that true no
that absolutely isn't true in fact since
I became Sean support secretary a couple
of months ago I met all the union
leaders I tried to change the tone of
the discussions and I said that
ministers would help facilitate the
trade unions and the employers that's
the train operating company's Network
rail getting around the table I made
sure there was a new and improved offer
that went to trade Union members that's
why two of the unions have settled on
network rail the rmt recommended though
sadly that their members should reject
that but even so a third of their
members wanted to accept it so look I
think in the New Year it's time for the
rmt to get off the picket line
background the negotiating table and
ministers will do what we can to
facilitate them coming to a deal with
the employers I want to get these rail
disputes sorted out for the benefit of
the traveling public so there's no
Clause that's been asserted at the last
minute about driver only trains look
driver only change is not a new thing
they've been um they've been in place
the unions it's always been a red line
they've been in place since the 1990s 55
of people that use trains are on
Services where there are driver only
operation Workforce reform is important
we've got to get rid of some of these
outdated working practices so for
example we can have a proper seven-day
Railway where the rail service isn't
dependent on people being rosted to work
on their days off that doesn't deliver a
good service for for passengers so we
need modern Railway a there's a fair and
reasonable offer on the table and I hope
the rmt looked to take it I mean you
know that the rmts say that they work
seven days a week and it's not an issue
about rostering they say that there's
not enough staff as well which is
perhaps part of the problem on those
Sundays when people aren't no look this
is this is because there are days of the
week when people don't have to work
they're not contracted to work and the
rail service depends on what's called
rest day working which is where people
are rostered to work on their days off
and if they don't want to come to work
the training companies find it very
difficult to run those Services that's
not a way to run a modern Railway we
need a proper seven-day Railway where
people are rostered on each day and have
to come to work on each day they're
contracted to work so that you can
deliver better services for passengers
it's that sort of Reform with a fair pay
package that we want to see to resolve
this has that been offered there has
been a fair and reasonable offer on the
table which is comparable to what most
people listening to this program will
have got across the economy two trade
unions accepted it that offer from
Network rail the rmt are holding out
against it and I hope they get
background in negotiating table off the
picket lines and we can try and hammer
out a deal between the employers and the
trading they're saying they want to talk
to you they said they've had no contact
for the past couple of weeks well no
look they met their rail minister so the
employers trade unions and the rail
Minister met before Christmas the rail
ministers continue to talk to them
across the Christmas period and we're
looking to have more meetings set up
next week I'd much rather those meetings
took place this week instead of strikes
taking place
um and that would be my message why are
they taking place this week then well
because the trade
unions because the trade unions decided
they wanted to go on strike this week
which is deeply unhelpful damages the
rail industry damages the interest of
the people that work in it I want to see
them back around the table we can try
and hammer out a deal between the
employers and the trade Unions that's
what I want to see happen that's what
I'm doing working really hard with the
rail minister to try and sort out is
there going to be an increase in the
offer to these striking workers in terms
of their benefits well look there's a
fair and reasonable payoff from the
table people look there's not a
bottomless pit of taxpayers money here
the taxpayers put a huge amount of
investment into the rail industry over
the last few years when it was hit with
a huge impact from the pandemic when
people weren't traveling and I think
it's you've got to have an offer that's
both fair to the people that work in the
industry but it's also fair to the
taxpayer that's picking up the tab and
that's the balance that we're trying to
strike I mean just a broader thought
about the government that you you
represent in Europe that's seeing all
this strike actions how does that feel
working in the government that has so
many people within the public sector and
the private sector out on strike because
of the the state of the economy and the
way that they feel the country is being
run well look it's not a surprise at the
moment with inflation being very high
we're seeing High inflation you know
driven by uh the war in Ukraine the high
energy prices it's not surprising that
people are under pressure that's why the
governments try to make reasonable
payoffers in the public sector that's
why for example we've accepted the
independent pay review borders in the
health service for example which was
above the government's own affordable
ability constraints but accepted that
offer in full to try and give people a
fair pay rise but look I accept things
are difficult at the moment we want to
try and get inflation back under control
that's the way that will help everybody
in the economy that's definitely the
ambition and do you ex do you accept
that more can be done by government to
try and get this resolve people are
asking questions about where the Prime
Minister has been people are asking
questions about Parliament being
recalled this week to try and resolve
some of these issues well the Prime
Minister has been working I think had a
short break and for Christmas day it's
been working across the Christmas period
we put in place those uh offers uh
before Christmas or pay we've accepted
the pay review bodies recommendations in
the health service for example and I
think ministers are going to continue
trying to do what we can to resolve
these disputes but as I said it has to
be fair both for the people that work in
the public sector but also for the
taxpayer that has to meet those bills
that's what the government's going to
continue trying to do now you said
you've not been able to speak to the rmt
so far this week you'd like to but I'm
going to be speaking to little while's
time what would you want to say to to
Mick Lynch well I I had a perfectly
constructive meeting when I met Mick
Lynch after I took on this job I'd say
look the real Minister's trying to get
some more meetings sorted out this week
let's get off the picket line let's get
around the negotiating table I made sure
there was an improved offer that went to
Trade union members let's try and Hammer
out the detail you get these disputes
resolved around the negotiating table
not on the picket line and that would be
my message to Mr Lynch okay my carpet
Transportation pleasure thank you very
much this morning while listening to
that was the head of the r t Mick Lynch
who is outside Houston Station at Mick
Lynch good morning to you so you heard
uh Mark Harper there says it wants you
to get off the picket line around the
table
well that's fine I heard a bit of it oh
I'd go and meet him now if he wants or
he can come here and meet me and we can
Hammer some things out
what we keep hearing is the same stuff
from the government uh across the
sectors that they want to facilitate
an agreement but they don't actually do
anything I met the rail Minister on the
15th along with the companies
we've heard nothing tangible since then
you hear a few warm words and Mark
Harper makes you know he conducts
himself in in a pleasant way in a good
way and that's fine so what we need to
hear now from the government is is
exactly what it is they're going to
propose to us at the moment they they
got themselves into a position before
Christmas where we were making progress
with the trade operating companies and
on one Sunday afternoon before a set of
strike action they decided to torpedo
those talks by putting in conditions on
the in the documentation they know that
we and the other unions can never accept
so that was a deliberate strategy which
frustrated the train operating company
Executives the most senior people in the
industry are as frustrated as we are
that the government will not facilitate
a settlement and indeed has taken the
opposite take of undermining efforts to
get a settlement they know that we can't
accept the current proposal so we need
to get a fresh uh set of elements in the
equation so that we can work up some
solutions rather than just put in some
warm words so as soon as Mark Harper and
his team want to meet us we'll be
available okay well he said he wants to
meet you this week but you're on the
picket line so he said he's going to
meet you next week but on that specific
point about torpedo
I don't understand this big hit line and
put the question to you first Mr Lynch
hold on so one sec on that particular
point about the government torpedoing
the negotiations I put that to him just
now he said that that's just not true
they haven't done that
well he's not telling you the truth
because we had a document with the train
operating companies that did not include
driver only operation it was taken away
for approval in Whitehall at the DFT and
they inserted about eight or nine bullet
points that completely undermined the
negotiations that was a direct
intervention of government ministers we
know that to be true and if he's saying
that didn't happen he's simply not
telling you the whole truth well he and
let me let me let me tell you what you
did say then he said that the driver
only trained things is is not really an
issue said 50 of trains are operated
driver only anyway it's basically saying
that that's a strongman argument that
you guys are putting why did they
insisted it going in the document then
fifty percent of the trains that don't
run on that way it's only seven seventy
percent run without it uh and most
trains are operating this country with
guards on board so they did insist on
doing that I had a document I was in a
meeting with the companies on a Sunday
afternoon uh out of hours in order to
walk work towards a settlement on the
Saturday on the Friday the document
didn't have those Clauses in and on the
Sunday the Clauses were reintroduced
as I said yeah no as I said that he he
denies that that happened let's let's
talk about where this goes from here he
can deny all he likes it doesn't mean
it's not true let's talk about where
this goes from here look you're out on
strike four days this week I mean what
do you think you've achieved in terms of
your strike action since you've been out
since the summer
well we brought this this issue to the
to the four what we've done is stop the
companies imposing a 50 cut in
maintenance schedule tasks taking risk
with Railway safety
we've stopped them imposing Mass
redundancies on our members and we've
brought the issue of the the lack of a
square deal for working people in
Britain to the front page of uh and the
front of all the news bulletins in the
country and we've woken up working
people to the fact that they're being
ripped off that they're underpaid and
their conditions are are under threat
right across our economy and right
across our society so that we've had a
game changer really across this year or
across 2022 in terms of what
working-class people are prepared to put
aren't we with and we've put the
government and corporate Britain Under
Pressure to give British workers a
square deal and give them value for
money for their labor
I mean do you get concerned though that
you might with all this disruption it's
the start of the new year you're going
to start alienating some of the public
with these tactics
well we don't want to alienate anyone we
want to run the railway service properly
we want a safe affordable Railway that's
running the interest of the people
rather than the profiteers the private
sector Railway companies that made
profit right through the covid pandemic
and every day during these strikes
they've made profits because the
government is subsidizing the strike so
we don't think we're losing public
support we're getting massive support
from people online in person on our
picket lines and even when our members
are at work on non-strike days the
traveling public is telling us they
support us they want a decent Railway
that's running their interests and they
don't want this inaction from the
government and profiteering from the
private sector Railway so as soon as we
can get a settlement and get the public
back on the railway and back to work and
using Leisure facilities to go about
their business the better for us and the
better for them yeah a mick Lynch I mean
on public support ipsos did some polling
that says that there was less support
for the strikes and December than there
was in October so it does seem to be
going down a little bit but we'll just
leave that there for now I mean look
there's a payoff run on the table isn't
there there's a there's an offer for um
conditions as well what more do you want
to see in terms of the offer because as
the transportation is saying there
that's there for you guys what more do
you want to see from them
well we the network rail offer there are
two different offers on the table the
network rail offer was rejected by our
members because of the conditions that
are on it it's not a terribly high value
uh pay offer so there's got to be an
improvement on the pay we're looking for
and we're looking for an agreement on
our conditions and we're looking for an
agreement on job security all of that is
achievable in the next few days the
companies know what they need to do and
they know what we could accept because
they're experienced people it's the
government that is stopping this happen
now I hope Mark Harper and you Merriman
can move this forward in the next few
days so that we can end this dispute
that we can put a set of proposals to
our members in referendums that they can
support but at the minute that's simply
not there our proposals and our needs
are quite modest from this this dispute
and if we can get towards a settlement
the happier we will be and our members
can get back to work you said an
agreement on job security I mean you've
got an agreement until 2025 on no
compulsory redundancies you want it to
go further than that
that's not particularly the issue the
length of the deal with network rail
it's what we've got to do we have to
accept a 50 cut in maintenance schedules
tasks on the railway the company wants
to introduce risk-based maintenance
rather than plan preventative
maintenance we think that's unsafe for
the public we think it's unsafe for our
people and it's not the way to run our
Railway on a more riskier basis than it
is there's also disruption to their
working lives and there are thousands of
job cuts on the table so we need a
settlement that addresses all of the
issues and not just one element
so if we can get that we can move this
forward as quickly as we can
and look there are talks come in as
we've heard and you said you wanted to
have talks with Mr Harper today if you
don't get what you want in these next
round of talks so you're going to step
up this action
well we've got a mandate that runs
through to May uh and we could probably
uh we would ballot again if we haven't
got a settlement we don't want to have
to do that we want to get our members
back to work so the quicker we can get
that the better but we have a mandate
for industrial election that runs on uh
all through the winter and all through
the spring and our members have voted
for industrial action twice and our
Network rail members have voted to turn
down the proposals that are on the table
so we need an improvement in the offer
so that we can get this thing sorted out
and if you don't get it what more days a
week out you're out four days this week
is it going to be seven days I mean that
next week where'd you take this to we've
got no action we've got no action uh on
the stocks at the moment we'll review
that next week when our members are back
at work uh and we'll consult our
Representatives around the country and
we'll decide what the next steps are
after that in the meantime I hope we can
get these discussions on if the
government is saying to me they want to
speak to us as quickly as possible we'll
deal with that before we set down any
more industrial action but we need to
get tangible improvements on what's been
proposed yeah you've made that point Mr
Lynch but I mean passengers who have
been disrupted on their commute back
into work this week people trying to get
around the country to see family and
stuff they'd like to try and know what
might be coming in the next couple of
weeks from Railway workers who are on
strike you're not going to tell us where
you might take this action you're
already out for four days as I said well
we haven't we haven't we haven't got a
schedule of uh further industrial
election at the moment what we do is we
put down a schedule of industrial
election we review what that what that's
done where the talks are and what our
members feel about the action that's
taken so after this action that finishes
on Saturday we'll review that early next
week along with any progress in the
talks that Mr Harper has
indicated he wants to achieve and we'll
see what needs to be done we don't have
a schedule set out six months in advance
we take it in stages and we'll do that
when we review where the dispute is next
week when when this phase is concluded
all right Mick lyncher from the rmt to
appreciate your time this morning thanks
for being with us
thank you
all right let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow news with us now
tomorrow good morning to you happy New
Year Of course um so look an accusation
there from Mick leave the mark Harper
was lion what do you make of that that's
right well a new year dominated by
strikes we've got a rail strikes every
day this week either by the rmt or by
the driver's Union as left and although
when Mark Harper became transport
secretary just a few weeks ago he said
that he wanted a grown-up
um and good faith approach and that was
the way he said to get a deal he said a
deal um was a possibility and this was
the way to do it rather than the
combative approach of his predecessor
Grant chaps it doesn't look like they
are getting very far both sides very
entrenched with now Mick Lynch accusing
Mark Harper of lying he says the
government are interfering and
preventing he says Network rail and the
train operating companies and from doing
a better deal on pay and also on
conditions something that the transport
secretary says isn't true so it looks
like they've got this mandate for
another few months it looks like there's
a very real possibility of more and more
strikes on the railways until the rmt
feel they've got a deal that their
members can agree to they got a very big
turnout and a big vote to reject the
latest deal from Network rail in
December which was for a five percent
increase last year four percent this
year but their big concern is changes to
some of the working practices which the
government say is inevitable and they
say that the longer this goes on the
more people will be put off taking the
trains and it won't seem like a viable
option for them so digging in there and
I think Tory MPS are very much being
geared up for legislation coming for
Parliament at some point in the next few
weeks to ensure minimum service levels
to force
um not to the rail networks but
potentially parts of the NHS as well to
provide a minimum service level I think
there is a difference though in how MPS
regard the rail strikes um Tory MPS have
no sympathy with um with the rail unions
and how they regard these huge pressures
in the NHS and there's going to be NHS
strikes later this month I think a lot
of them have very worried about that
okay tomorrow for now thank you very
much for that right let's take a quick
look at the front pages of the mornings
newspapers now and we'll start with the
times Millions will show trains forever
is the front page of that paper they say
a generation of passengers will put off
train travel due to the recent strikes
the guardian reports that the NHS faces
three months of turmoil amid long Waits
and staff shortages
the mirror says that the future of the
Health Service is on a knife edge while
the Daily Mail looks at comments made by
Prince Harry about the royal family
ahead of the release of the first part
of his Memoirs next week it's headline
Harry I'd like my father and brother
back
the telegraph also leads with the
interview and reports Prince Harry's
claims that the king and Prince of Wales
are unwilling to reconcile
well the sun says that Prince Harry has
slated his family again
or to the United States now when
President Biden is facing renewed
pressure over the contents of a laptop
that belongs to his son Hunter the
president's Republican opponents have
pledged to use the new session of
Congress which begins tomorrow to
investigate allegations around his
involvement in his son's business
Affairs President Biden insists that he
had no knowledge of his son's business
dealings our U.S correspondent James
Matthews reports
this is a story of what the computer
repairman saw and of questions it asks
around secrecy and a sitting president
any kind of sarcastically said Biden
like kind of expecting me to know who he
was John Paul mckiser was handed a
laptop for repair
by Hunter Biden son of Joe in the months
before the 2020 election
John Paul who's visually impaired showed
us some of the content he kept
the addiction struggles of the
president's son are well documented but
it's not images of drug taking or
self-made pornography that's raising
questions as much as the email traffic
uh the announcement of my guys upcoming
travels now now my guy hunter refers to
his father as my guy award the chairman
or the big guy emails appear to suggest
that Biden Jr was used for access to
Biden senior when he was vice president
and his son was on the board of a
Ukrainian Energy company why they lie to
the American people because he was fully
aware of his son's business dealings he
was a tool of those dealings
it's a computer repair shop that two
years ago was a starting point for a
story that had the look of a
pre-election scandal
it was reported by the New York Post but
the tale that emerged from Wilmington
Delaware hometown of the bidens didn't
travel as far as it might have
John Paul McIver handed the laptop to
the FBI it won Facebook and Twitter of
the potential for Russian disinformation
ahead of the election
the tech companies then restricted the
laptop story on their platforms Joe
Biden's Republican opponents call it
election suppression the laptop and its
contents had already triggered their
plans for an investigation this evident
rate is troubling questions about
whether President Biden is a national
security risk
and about whether he is compromised by
Foreign government
the story of the laptop that landed here
comes with quotes from the President Joe
Biden was a candidate when it first came
to light before the last election he
dismissed that then as disinformation a
Russian plant he's also said that he's
never had discussions with his son about
any of his overseas business dealings
it's the story that stalks the Biden
still Republicans now have a majority in
the House of Representatives that opens
the door to an investigation once closed
they saw Injustice at a would-be scandal
undersold now they see opportunity to
sell it once more
James Matthews Sky News in Wilmington
Delaware
now ski resorts across the Alps are
being forced to turn away holiday
wankers because a lack of snow a spell
of unseasonably warm weather has turned
much of the snow to slush particularly
at some of the main resorts in France
and Western Switzerland temperatures and
parts of Switzerland over the New Year
reached 20 degrees
and this weekend's skiing World Cup
event in the village of adelboden will
be run entirely on artificial snow
and with parts of the world experiencing
a stream weather conditions I mean 20
degrees at Christmas in the Alps let's
have a look at the impact of climate
change on the planet as you can see
that's our climate change dashboard on
the right hand side you've got the UK's
current power mix 25 of our powers
coming from gas right now naught percent
from coal which is good and 52.5 from
Renewables which is also excellent on
the top left you can see how much warmer
the Earth is now since 1880 and in the
bottom left for the total CO2 emissions
since records began
now after the break I'll be speaking to
the former Health secretary Stephen
Doral as the government search to act
over warnings that the pressure on the
NHS is unbearable
[Music]
hello and welcome back now the
government has been warned that the
pressure on the NHS is unbearable and
intolerable and is facing calls to do
more to help the service through its
winter crisis more than a dozen NHS
trusts and ambulance services declared
critical incidents over the festive
period the British Medical Association
says that the government's political
choices are leading to patients dying
unnecessarily joining us now is the
former Health secretary and former chair
of the NHS Confederation Stephen Doral
Stephen Doral good to have you with us
this morning thanks for joining us I
mean good morning intolerable unbearable
the NHS is just about broken
well I don't believe the NHS is broken
but it's clearly under huge pressure
It's Not Unusual of course for the
Health Service to be under pressure at
this time of year with people with flu
you can probably hear I've got it flu
and the covid and the the normal
pressures that come at this time of year
but I think it's also true that there
are some steps the government now needs
to take to relieve the pressure it can't
remove uh the the pressure of uh high
demand and stretched capacity but there
are some things it can do that will
improve the situation first of all it
can obviously it can address the pay
disputes it's going to get worse during
January if we've got pay disputes going
on in the background and the second is
the thing that people don't often think
about when they think about pressures in
a e departments is that the the it is
possible for the government to intervene
quickly to improve the position in
Social care and if you can support
people in the community outside the
hospital system you relieve the
pressures within the hospital system
okay Stephen let's go through both of
those things and first let's start with
social care you may have heard the
minister Mark Harper saying that more
money is going into the Health Service
specifically into social care to try and
alleviate those pressures you said the
government can do something quickly what
could they do
well it is about money it's also about
ensuring that there are proper
Arrangements in place locally to join up
the Health and Social care system
anybody who's experience of the Health
and Social care system knows that there
are repeated incidents repeated
occasions when the different parts of
Health and Social care don't work
properly together and so joining them up
and providing more money for social care
is actually the quickest single thing
the government can do to relieve the
pressure on a e departments and
emergency Wards in hospitals
and you also said address the pay
dispute that you're expecting the
government to meet the pay demands of
the RCN
well the RCN themselves have said uh
that they're in they're looking for a
negotiation they've put a a request on
the table and then said they want to
negotiate it's the secretary of state
who's refusing to meet them to talk
about hey they'll talk about uh the
secretary of state says he'll talk about
everything except pay what are the union
leaders supposed to do when their
members see that their representatives
can talk about the everything except the
thing that their members want to see
address
and of course you know uh Stephen Doyle
that pay is is a huge part of this but
also its conditions it's the the just
the simple numbers of people who are on
the wards oftentimes safe Staffing is is
how the RCN put it I mean how do you
address that in the in the in the near
term
the the the answer is there's a staffing
issue around doctors and nurses right
around the world actually there's a
global shortage of people with the
necessary skills as doctors and nurses
and and paramedics uh so you can't
there's no magic wand that can be waived
but what you can do is treat the
workforce that you've got in the wards
in the hospitals and in the community
treat them now properly the problem at
the moment is that people are leaving
the Health and Social care system
because they don't feel they're being
treated properly that is an issue The
Government Can address quickly
yesterday I spoke to Matthew Taylor who
said that it's been those austerity as
chronic underfunding in the NHS that's
led up to this point that we find
ourselves at now do you agree with that
well it's always true that if you've got
more money you can do more that's I
agree with that the thing the part of
the system that where I think the
funding pressures have been greatest is
the social care system we were
discussing a moment ago and what's
happened over quite a prolonged period
is that social care uh Arrangement the
structures of social care have been
withdrawn from cases that would
previously have benefited from it the
result is those people come into
hospital or they presented the GPS and
the primary care system they rely on the
Health Care system when they actually
didn't need to if they'd been properly
supported in the community
and Stephen Doyle I mean I didn't want
to come back to this but you do keep
mentioning fixing social care I just
want to get some more detail of what
that actually looks like you say get
people out of Hospital there's 12 000
people can be discharged from hospital
right now I as I understand it they will
go from hospital to where
well each case will be different can I
just pick up the point that there are 12
000 delayed discharges in the jargon in
the Health Service people who are in
hospital who shouldn't didn't need to be
there it's worth remembering that for
every case of a somebody who could be
discharged from hospital there are four
cases of people who are avoidable
admissions people who should never have
been in hospital in the first place so
if you address social care that means
ensuring that you've got funding for uh
people for social workers to support
people at home for David for care visits
to support people in the home it also
means ensuring that where people could
be properly looked after uh in a
residential care home or a or a nursing
home that is both better for the
individual and also as it happens lower
cost to the exchequer so if you support
those Services you end up with fewer
people in hospital but also fewer people
rely dying on the NHS community services
including primary care and GP services
so it comes back again doesn't it to
funding and Staffing more money for the
facilities and more money for social
workers
it does come back to Staffing but
there's Staffing and money yes it does
but there's there's always a tendency to
look at the part of the system where the
pressures are most acute and most
obvious which is in a e departments and
emergency admissions in hospital
actually the root cause of many of those
admissions delayed discharges cases
arriving in hospital is inadequate
support in the community you can deliver
better care at lower cost if you address
the questions of social care which is
the the if you look across Health and
Social care as a single system it's
actually social care that has taken the
Lion's Share of the spending pressures
over the last 15 years
okay Stephen Doyle a former Health
secretary really good speak to you this
morning thanks very much for your time
thank you